How's It Going Everyone!!
*"Everyone"*
*sexy mustache close-up*
EvErYoNe
(100% Family Friendly)
This is an all inclusive
"Safe" Channel
Where everyone can feel safe
No swearing,
No offensive humour,
Nothing...
TRIGGERING
And I found
the most peaceful,
wonderful game
(improvised pause)
ever
So That
Everyone!
EVERYONE!!
can enjoy this game.
I am talking of course about
Hand Simulator
See this hand?
Useless, useless piece of
Garbage Hand
This get handed....
IT'S GARBAGE
We're playing the real deal here
OK
We can select shooting or spinners
I'm gonna go with shooting
Play please
Wow
Wow!
This feels...
This Feels Right! This Feels Just Like the same- oh wow look at this you can't do that in real life.... you can no
No not stop What i say hand
That's It alright Can I move my Other one oh
Wow, I can Touch My other hand with my other hand. I need Help.  I can Only control One hand at a time
ok...
Alright so these are the fingers
it's almost like that other game
Surgeon Simulator
But it's not ripping it off at all
Look I am making a Bad no
No, no not that that Was close that was close ok ok now slowly
Slowly
This Feels Just Like a Reality
How do I move it down mouse Wheel ok?
Yes okay let's grab that Yes so
okay that didn't Work oh This is Insanely hard
I'm not sure what I'm doing right now....
Oh!
Maybe I need to charge it up
Oh my god....
Oh!
Wait What is this oh wow let me Just a grab it
How in the world how am i supposed to reload a gun oh my god i have to do it oh?
Wow okay alright fine my Hand Is a Little Broken But That's okay
Which are my Index fingers use the thumb
How
You made an input did i grab it now i don't even know if i can grab it oh i think i got it
This is like pinching The World's Smallest Nipple What the Actual come here
How great i can't Reach That far Great it's impossible oh?
Oh, oh oh i got it i got it i got it okay okay now somehow
we're gonna put It in
How... How...
My God we're so close Finger It Finger It in
Flick it in
*sexy pewdiepie sounds*
How
you Know What reset reset
Listen okay i think i'm the only one in
The Whole World Who Played This game  un-ironically you know what i mean grab it like a Real gun
This is how you grab a Real gun
Right
Right I have it I have it in my hand
MM MM MM MM MM
Mm-hmm all right, gonna angle it down
Down
we're gonna
Know i flicked It back in again ugh
Yeah that's not physics work okay get that button there hit the button hit the goddamn button
Hit the Got thank you
ssss grab the gun
The gun alright Yeah
Switch hand again okay we've got the bullet Here
*CLAP*
(RIP HEADPHONE USERS)
Duck you, Duck you
Let me do the Spinners okay i'll do the spinners thank you for oh wow look at That
Look at that this is way better, oh my god yes I think I will go
With this one Hmm
Wow look at that
Wow look at that oh this Looks like a sharp one.
Oh wow that one's... That one's there okay maybe we should try this hand huh
Look at this look at that one that one's spinning
look at that that one spun pretty good
Hey look at that
WOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
Yeeeeeah
Remember when Steam used to have standards yeah I want to die
This is where I want to die. What is multiplayer then huh
Mexican Stand Up I tweeted out for someone to join but I guess no one else is that stupid
No one's this stupid huh oh my god someone Joined oh my god it's what okay okay press the button
press the Button
Pressed
Press the button
Someone actually bought this stupid game. Press the Button. It Looks a Bit Weird When I have my arm right, no, no, no
No, no, no, no no stop. Oh he's pressing button. Do you want to hold Hands? Hey Hey
oOOoOooOoOOoOooOh
*chuckle*
Oh my hand
What is he doing pointing at me no, no, no, no no stop, stop
*quiet laugh*
This is the dumbest game I have ever Played With anyone
Oh wow that looks good, that looks really good.... Oh my god
Try to finger me oh?
Oh wow
You're right there buddy. Why does my hands feel so weird? It's because you never used them before. 'Kay let's try another one
Gunfighter ok we're doing a standoff
A gunfight. Where's the gun though? do the WOPPA GANGNAM STYLE Whoop no wait wait where do the kids do the naenae huh is that
Do the Whip
Onan na I do the whip whip and doodlenet. Pewdiepie 2017.This is the most enthrilling
Multiplayer experience I've had in my life
Oh there, there is someone, wow someone joined. Hey
This is so sh*t
HELLOOOOOO!
Ohmygod.
Oh sh*t, there's 3 of us
Oh damn
Dude I like your pants okay okay kay kay kay kay kay all right cool it started it started
Who's gonna live huh oh god he's got the gun
He's dropped the gun
He can't reach it now
yes this is my chance okay I got the gun
I got the gun alright all right all right I got the gun this is so exciting alright switch switch hand
We just gotta hit that button. How you guys doing over there
He can't reach his gun
*Dying whale sounds*
Flawless game. I guess he can Steal his gun technically. This game is ready for e-sports
There it is. Okay, now I just gotta grab one of the bullets
Duck
Oh I think I nailed it
Whoa!
Look at that!
okay okay okay okay okay okay now
Somehow.
Somehow get that bullet.
Oh my god I'm gonna be I there's a chance
NOOOOOO!
It's too hard. Has anyone ever done it? It's okay I got three more chances. I think I got it. I'm getting good at this
I'm gonna see if i can put this... he's trying to take his gun. Maybe this is a better angle? Yeah it is okay
No, now i can't reach. He's he holding up. I'm coming for you dude, I'm coming for you, don't you worry. I'm clearly doing this
with the wrong hand.
Duck this. Let's play Melon Simulator. God damn it. Early Access game huh, I'm sure this one will be completed
What the hell is happening?
What? What is happening? What is going on?
Oh, it's melon
Wow, video games have really come far. Nice job team
Thanks for leaving a like on this video and I'll see you tomorrow with another video
Probably not as good as this one, cuz this is gonna be hard to top I really feel like squad fam out
This was a pain to edit the subtitles on, like seriously.